[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
good day walter hello martin how are you
doing
you asked me the same question every
time for 66 times already
yeah so this is a bad number yeah
so let's ask for the holy spirit to help
us again
our heavenly father thank you very much
for bringing us together again
we ask that you please bless us again
and that the holy spirit will enlighten
our minds enlighten the viewers and
guide our discussion in jesus name amen
amen
so martin we're going down history lane
today
yes yes because we have so many
questions about this first
day of the week and the rapture
and all of these issues
and the mark of the beast and
whether you know yeah i think there's a
misconception a lot of people
don't know the history we must look at
the history
because once you look at the history
then you get a nice picture of where we
are today
yes and and history tells us what the
issues were
now we did one on coercion right
correct and it's always interesting to
me
if you find this coercion all the way
back
in history then basically you can
use coercion as your yardstick and say
whether something is from god or
not definitely yes yeah and i think a
lot of
um misconceptions like i said earlier
will be get will be out of the way once
you understand where everything comes
from
yes and that's why one must do a little
bit of
historic research
and it's interesting that you cannot
trust every source
yeah because history has sometimes
been rewritten correct and that's very
important
and therefore you need to know both
sides of the story before you can trust
the historic account
especially in the religious environment
yes
considering that there was persecution
and ostracizing certain groups etc
so we have to be very careful what
historic sources
we trust correct so let's look at this
issue of pre-terrorism futurism
dispensationalism
who is the antichrist the mark of the
beast
and talk about it
let's start off with conservative
catholicism
yes right out of the horse's mouth right
out of the horse's mouth and see
what they have to say now conservative
catholicism
clings to vatican one
the council of trent whatever the
decisions were that were
made at the council of trent those are
the ones that are still excated
from the bishop's seat infallible
and everything else that doesn't fit
into that mindset
seems to be at loggerheads with it
when in actual fact it might not be
because whatever is not excuted i could
be anything
so dr taylor marshall has this youtube
channel where he defends the council of
trent
ideology and he's very much against this
openness of the vatican two popes
we need to talk about this in some
detail
this will definitely lead to to those
lectures that we'll do about that or
discussions yes
and it's also important for
non-catholics other christian
denominations to listen to what he says
because there's quite a lot of
historical things
that he says in this video that can
pertain to them
exactly so he's going to talk about
the temple the antichrist
and what the view of jerome augustine
catholic church fathers yes john
christodam
the dorad theophalactus
and perhaps gregory great had to say
the second view is the temple
what does the temple mean the antichrist
is it in a building in jerusalem saint
john of damascus
and robert bellamine were of that view
and then he talks about thessalonians
about
sitting in the temple of god and
you are the temple of god so it's
interesting to see
what he says from the conservative
catholic
point of view there's two
two camps on this one the temple
means that the antichrist that's the ac
i put ac
here the temple means the ac will be
adored
in the church okay now who taught that
in church history
saint jerome saint augustine
saint john chrysostom theodorate
theophylactus
and perhaps gregory the great now the
second view
still on this right here is that temple
means that the antichrist will be adored
in a building in jerusalem
and the major advocates of that are
saint john of damascus
and saint robert bellarmine remember
saint robert bellarmine
is writing against protestants and all
the protestants
martin luther john calvin john knox
kramner all of them believed that the
pope in rome was
an antichrist so robert bellarmine wants
to show that no the popes are not
antichrist he has a whole section
i mean multiple chapters robert
bellermann on it
showing that against luther and calvin
know the
the antichrist shouldn't be in rome he
should be in jerusalem
now here's the quote here from robert
bellarmine
he says saint john damascus says in the
temple not
ours but the jewish temple that's john
damascus
and then bowerman says chrysostom
theodore and theophylactus who say
antichrist is going to sit in the
churches of christians
but they also say he's going to sit in
the temple of solomon
all right now i actually find myself
siding with saint john chrysostom here
saint john criticism says
that yes the antichrist will have his
capital
in jerusalem why do we know that because
all the church fathers say the
antichrist the final
antichrist will be jewish he will
enforce circumcision and he will enforce
keeping the sabbath on saturday that is
all throughout the church fathers
we also know from the book of the
apocalypse that the antichrist
kills the two witnesses which tradition
identifies as
enoch and elias kills them in jerusalem
so it seems that the antichrist activity
is within jerusalem
but yet chrysostom theodora and
theophylactus say the antichrist is
going to sit in the christian churches
and in the temple of solomon and if you
think about this this makes sense
if the antichrist is going into his
desires to be worshipped by everyone
and accepted by everyone that means
that if his capital were to be in
jerusalem that means that even the
so-called christians
these are the christians who have faded
and moved towards antichrist
they're also going to acknowledge and
worship antichrist
some way that's what the whole point of
the mark of the beast is about
saint john chrysostom says he will
command himself to be worshipped as a
god
and to be placed in the temple not only
in jerusalem
but even in the churches
all right so st john chrysostom says
it's not it's not just
one or the other it's not like here one
or two
it's actually both that's how
persuasive the antichrist is going to be
at the end of the world
well that's a mouthful but that's
basically
what the church fathers of the roman
catholic system
taught yes and cardinal
bellamine was a jesuit of course
embellished it a little bit in his
writings and wanted to make sure
that the protestant view
is discarded yes because after all you
can't have the pope being the antichrist
right
so they made the times of daniel literal
times
which is interesting in itself because
it
means that they recognize that daniel
was speaking about the antichrist
yes all right yeah and uh
it's interesting that they then apply
that
to a future antichrist that will come
so that the pope cannot be the
antichrist so here is a
is a whole lot of confusion and we need
to
we need to look at this very carefully
yes because a lot of the christian world
today
teach the same teachings basically all
of them
[Music]
and they get very confused some of the
conservative
ones believe in pre-terrorism
but we'll we'll look at that so we need
to understand
where this comes from why there is so
much
confusion and
why the world has to believe what these
people are saying
because then the heat is off yes of
their true antichrist the roman catholic
system
so if we go to daniel chapter 7 where we
have the chapter
on the little horn it tells us about
this little horned power
in actual fact it's not a little horn
it's a horn that grew from littleness
but it
became more stout than his fellows
now if you take the attributes of that
little horned power
they are so accurate
when he would arise how he would arise
where he would arise what he would do
he would persecute the saints he would
change
times he would abrogate laws
he would uproot every other three
kingdoms
etc there is only one power
that fits them all and that's the roman
catholic church
now we're not going to give a lecture on
daniel 7 you can put a link in
yeah the man behind the mask is one of
the lectures on the antichrist and then
twin pillars of the reformation there's
another lecture that deals with that
kind of issue
but one of the attributes there is that
this power would
speak great words against the most high
so he's an antichrist power
but the word anti also means in the
place of
so he sits in the temple
and will read what he has to say he
shall wear out the saints so he'll make
war against
god's people and to
think to change times and laws there's a
very interesting wording there
because you cannot change god's law
correct
you cannot change god's times they're
fixed
so it will seem like it yes and
everybody will be
maybe adhering to what to this but you
cannot cannot change cannot change it
but he'll think to do it yes
so he'll attempt to do it now
when you're talking about time where was
time set in motion
in genesis in genesis chapter 1 the
rhythm of the week was introduced
and the seventh day was the rest day
that was the rhythm of the week that's
it there have been attempts in history
to
change it to a 10-day cycle to
no cycle at all or whatever it never
worked
the world is at the seventh day
seven-day cycle
and then there's this time prophecy they
shall be given into his hand until the
time
times and the dividing a time or a
a year two years and half a year
that's how it is translated in other
places
so the protestants used the day year
principle
and made this prophetic time
so a year in the hebrew calendar had 360
days
so 360 times three and a half is 1260
yes did the papal power
actually rule as a political entity
because a horn is a political entity for
260 years and the answer is yes
yes because vigorous ascended the papal
chair in 538 a.d
and took secular power
under his control after having
eradicated the three opposing powers yes
that the bible talks about and then he
ruled as a political entity until
1798 exactly 1260 years
and then he received a mortal wound when
his secular power was taken away not his
religious power no
but the bible says that wound would be
healed and he
would again be a power to be reckoned
with and the whole world will
wander after the beast
and in 1929 he got his
secular power back when the vatican
state was formed
and he again qualified as a beast
power correct so that is history
now this is the history that was not
mentioned in our video at all
right if you go to the
history source here is christ an
antichrist in prophecy
by edwin the and it says episcopal
elevation
laid the indispensable groundwork for
the development of the papacy
the second factor favoring it was the
fact that the pope began his career
as the bishop at rome the imperial
capital the capital had moved to
constantinople
in the east yes and so there was a
vacancy
which was controlled and taken over
by germanic tribes
and only when the three opponents were
removed
could the papacy actually take that
power unto itself
no evidence exists that in priscilla's
time
or for the next 80 years there even was
a bishop at rome in paul johnson's list
of pontiffs we read that
peter's alleged successor linus
67-76 was probably
an historical person but still not
technically a
bishop only number 10 pius the first
140-55
after christ is designated as such
for those who nevertheless insist that
the eternal sister
city must have had a pontiff from the
very beginning of the christian religion
we suggest that their name was pope
priscilla
he's being somewhat sarcastic yes
this priscilla is the one mentioned in
by paul
correct in the bible because there's no
mention of anything
else that is going on there so this is
the
the fact of history that the papacy
only really took
political power after 538 and this was
way before then
and it also where the papacy says
that the first pope was peter
correct this negates that as well
history negates it
absolutely and the interesting thing is
of course the emperors were still
ruling from rome until the time of
constantinople
and there's a lot of people in other
christian denominations that also say
that jesus handed over the power of the
church
to peter by declaring that part of
on this rock i'll build my church right
and we've shown that that's not
the case it's not he was not the rock
correct
let's just look at a little bit of the
history
of how the papacy
managed to assume the powers which it
claims to have
because those powers are nowhere
mentioned in the bible
nobody has them right not peter
nobody not one of the disciples nobody
so how did it go
from a servant leadership
that christ demonstrated to a rulership
and from being a minister to a priest
because a priest is someone who
brings a sacrifice
a minister is someone who ministers the
word
so this is a very interesting issue
so the priesthood of aaron
which was a sacrificial priesthood
because they sacrificed
animals that came to an end
so how did it become a priesthood again
you had to have a sacrifice
and you had to have an altar and that's
where roman catholicism brought in an
altar
and declared that the lord's supper was
an re-enactment a literal re-enactment
of what happened at the cross and they
became
priests and then as such they assumed
some powers which are totally foreign to
the bible
so here's a little bit of the history
the first one
to plant the first pig
was ignazius of antioch
in the first part of the second century
ignazius
the bishop of syrian antioch wrote
several letters while being escorted
under armed guard to rome
where he was martyred in his letter we
encountered
for the first time an ecclesiology
which exalts one bishop over the rest of
the presbyterian
so now you had the idea that
someone over here was more important
than someone over there
whereas we're supposed to be brothers
and sisters
and on the same level right yes
the next one was irenaeus and that was
in the second century he introduced
virtual infallibility that's interesting
so the early church knew nothing of this
rome based apostolic succession on
irenaeus
in his against heresies he links bishops
through the rite of ordination all the
way back to peter
irenaeus also developed the concept of
infallibility
veritatis satum and he also developed
the basis
for catholic marian theology
so here you have basically the rot
beginning to set in right early
early this is the second century already
i mean the devil's not going to sleep
for a century or two he's going to get
to business right away right
the next one was titillian and he
develops
clarification that means he makes a
distinction between
clergy and laity now it's interesting
when we discuss
bible translations the placing of a
comma becomes a very important
issue from the apostles and elders
and brethren to the brethren
as opposed to from the apostles and
elders
comma to the brethren then you have a
distinction right
not so in the early church then some are
more important than the other
exactly so in the new testament the
greek word
cleros can mean lot as in casting lots
or that which is assigned by lot or
portion
or share paul wrote that god has enabled
christians to share
in the inheritance claro of the saints
of light
and christians as heirs clero nomi
according to the promise in this sense
all
christians constitute the clergy
that's biblical acts
15 here we have those verses and they
wrote letters
by them after this manner the apostles
and elders and brethren
sent greetings unto the brethren which
of the gentiles in antioch syria and
sicilia that's the king james version
the modern translations like the end i
be the apostles and elders comma
your brothers that's not what it says so
this is a deliberate
distortion to gratify the philosophy of
rome
yes so that came in
via tatillion and then cyprian was the
next one
he elevates the clerics to the position
of priests
so this is yeah quite a while afterwards
right
cyprian claimed that the bishop is a
sacrificing priest
both jews and gentiles were familiar
with the idea of priests and sacrifices
but cyprian was the first to relate this
new religion
christianity with the older ones in this
way
basically martin what he did
he got rid of the ultimate sacrifice
which was christ
yes and he reverted back to a type
the earlier doctrine of the priesthood
of all believers
began to be abandoned and slipped into
the background
almost into oblivion inceprion is found
the germ of the division of the
sacrament
into two so that they gave you the host
only and not the wine
that became a major issue in the
reformation as well
the eucharist the sacrifice of
thanksgiving the mass
a new development and now the bishop
became a sacrificing priest and the
bloodless
but real sacrifice that he offered was
the passion of our lord
so that's how it crept in then once you
had the
basis then you could become
prescriptive because you were above
the rest so now we must look
at the origin of sunday keeping in
history
because we have said over and over
that the mark of the beast can only be
defined by the beast
itself correct and the criteria
that we have for the beast or such that
they
only apply to the roman catholic system
100 that's what all the reformers taught
without exception yes and that is what
the bible teaches
correct and there were earlier
proponents of the idea as well and they
were often martyred
so we won't go into all of that history
so this has been coming a long time
and roman catholicism as the beast
claims
that the change from sabbath to sunday
is a
mock of her ecclesiastical power yes
and we have to look at history to see if
this was so from the beginning
correct did the christians easily go
over from
the real sabbath to sunday absolutely we
need to know that
justin martyr and others like him
found a good deal of common ground
between christianity
and mithraism now mitraism
was the persian sun sun god worship
and under the elite
the leaders yeah of rome it had become
a favorite particularly because the way
in which it was constructed
how mitrea the
the organization of the groupings
how they were run that suited their
purpose
imported from persia it had begun to
strike
root in the roman world by the first
century a.d
by the second it was flourishing
so it's interesting right in this early
christian period
there was a shift in rome
from the worship of one deity to the
worship of another deity
and the sun god became prominent in the
first two centuries yes it's also
important
to realize that rome that they're
talking about in the roman world
here was still pagan that was the pagan
roman world
and the emperors and the elite
its popularity in rome was practically
as old as christianity itself
for nero began to espouse it
two centuries before constantine
hadrian 117-38
also identified himself with the sun as
is attested by his coins
many of our current practices come from
mitraism the 25th of december was the
birthday
of mitras the first day of the week
dedicated to the sun was his holy day as
opposed to the jewish sabbath this is
just
history it took the step of
shifting the emphasis from the
crucifixion
to the resurrection which would always
be celebrated on a
sunday according to frank jost
this change originated with pope
sixtus the first 115-125
a.d the bishop or pope of the capital
city
so these early bishops weren't really
called popes
but they were trying to get
stature by aligning themselves with
the roman hierarchy yes so if we
continue our history
but this was not at first a weekly
observance
coming once each week after the sabbath
as it was later and as it is today
it was annual now this is very important
it started with a
yearly sabbath or a yearly
sunday if we bring this to modern day
don't we see this happening right now
again absolutely
aren't they talking about yearly sunday
yes for the earth yes and then it's
supposed to become
more and more then when you look at
polish legislation
it was first once a month and then it
was going to be twice a month
and then it was going to be every week
yeah so now by i think the end of this
year or i can't remember exactly we did
what's a profit it had to be every year
every year every sunday sunday
this is a strategy that was practiced in
historic times already
it's interesting there's a saying
history repeats itself
yeah i've already told the story of my
cat
i had a dog and the cat always used to
sleep on top of the dog remember that's
right
and when the dog got old had too many
pains and it didn't like the cat
sleeping on top
so when the cat tried to climb onto the
dog it would go up
and the cat then would
slowly slowly put one paw
after the other and sit frozen for a
while
until she was on top of the dog this is
how they work this is how it works
so weekly sunday keeping would grow out
of this
practice anthony wilhelm a modern
catholic writer puts it in a nutshell
each sunday is a little easter
so the annual sunday
became a weekly sunday but how did it
happen
in the second century the pagan romans
changed their weekly calendar
of seven days they didn't change
the number of the days they changed an
order up to that time their traditional
solar deity who was apollo
had not been the chief of the gods
jupiter was the number one god
consequently the second day of the week
had been dedicated to the sun
the first day was
saturn day because they worshipped
saturn right
but now because of mithraism the sun god
had grown much more important
thereupon in a bit of drastic calendar
reform the romans pushed the sun's day
back into first position calling it dear
solace day of the sun
and this is how sunday came into
existence with a name
that has it that it has retained to the
present but remember it was a pagan day
yes and that's why i just want to make
clear here when they were
speaking in a year for of the first day
was saturn day that's in the roman
that's the roman week don't confuse it
with the biblical don't confuse this
with the biblical one this is
pagan history so now sunday
dear solace became a
roman day of
special significance so mural pictures
in pompeii
and herculaneum buried and preserved by
lava and volcanic ash from the vesuvius
eruption in 1879 clearly show the day of
the sun
as the second day on the calendar
so this is history yes so this is very
interesting
history so this is how sunday
came first to the pagan world
then from a slightly later period there
are several
mithraya or sanctuaries of the pagan sun
god
mitra which depicted as the first day
so there was the switch so they shifted
so what they did is
they took their pagan calendar and now
they're
all weak and now it came into harmony
with the biblical week
but they celebrated the first day and
not the seventh
like the bible correct and it was a
pagan issue
this change in the weekly calendar of
the romans could be used to bring
christians and pagans together for both
religions held celebrations on the first
day
the mithraics observed each sunday
and the roman christians it's very
important to note that
it was the roman christians and we'll
see why later
celebrated easter on it once a year
soon events would cause them to make an
even more
drastic adjustment and this is where it
comes in now
in ad-135 at the conclusion
of that war the second jewish revolt
in which many romans perished a furious
emperor hadrian issued a decree to
outlaw jewish worship
particularly their sabbath keeping
you see when the jews
rebuilt jerusalem
after the first destruction in 70 a.d
they were constantly
at loggerheads with the romans
and in the revolt they killed many
romans
and hadrian the emperor was furious
and he decided to eradicate judaism from
the face of the earth
yes so he sent in his soldiers they
totally destroyed jerusalem in a
greater destruction than it had in 70
a.d
and he outlawed the jewish religion so
basically he ended the jewish statehood
and he scattered them and if forbade
their worship which included sabbath yes
so there came an addict
against the sabbath nobody was allowed
to keep it
now the early christians were in trouble
yes what now
because they kept saturday they had the
annual
in rome easter but now
they faced the state the power
of the state and the pressure was
on to conform to sunday
yes because otherwise you get persecuted
so the bishop of rome
well he wanted to maintain his position
of influence
came up with the idea well
what if we move over to the sunday
because we have an annual
sunday we'll celebrate the resurrection
and we'll tell the emperor
that we agree with dear solace the
venerable day of the sun
and so in rome they shifted later
in alexandria they shifted as well
but the rest of the christian world kept
sabbath yes they kept
strong on the on the seventh day of the
week
so this was the first anti-sabbath
law that the church had to face at that
time believers generally were still
observing the seventh day
in accordance with one of the ten
commandments and only the fourth
instead of enduring the test however the
pope
took a radical step he changed their day
of worship to sunday by extending
easter celebrations into weekly
observance so that's the history
how it came about and this war has been
raging ever since
we know that the church in the east kept
the sabbath
we know that the thomas sites
up until the time of the jesuits after
the reformation
still kept the seventh day of the week
and
where were they and they were in india
india yes because
according to them saint thomas
had come and brought the gospel to them
and they were sabbath keepers
the celts had kept sabbath the valdez
kept sabbath right throughout the dark
ages the albigenses
kept the sabbath right throughout the
dark ages
and there's pretty good evidence that
the three enemies yeah they're ruling
the visigoths and the ostrogoths
that they also kept the sabbath although
we don't have that history
because we only have roman catholic
sources left after their destruction
so this is how the weekly sunday
came in in rome
precedent and rationalization
undoubtedly played a powerful role the
state had already demonstrated its
ability to change the weekly calendar
if pagan romans could shift the sun's
day from the second to the first
then surely christian romans could move
the lord's day
from the seventh to the first and that
would solve a lot of problems
persecution by the state would then be
over
in this way the will of the pope rather
than the scriptures
became the primary basis for determining
what the faithful should believe
and so a mere century after the
crucifixion
the pontiffs apostasized abandoning the
idea that the bible was the sole
authority for faith and doctrine
naturally some believers in rome could
not accept such a drastic change
just because the ecclesiastical
leadership wanted it
therefore to develop a theological
justification for the worshipping on the
day of the sun
christians appealed to god's creation
weak
it's interesting now they justifying
they have to rationalize rationalize it
because the creation of light on the
first day provided what appeared to many
a providential
justification for observing the day of
the sun
it's pretty ridiculous because there was
no sun on the first day it only came on
the fourth day right
correct but this is a justification
martin do we hear similar arguments
today
yes 100 it's like arguments that the cat
dragged in right brought it back from
2 000 years almost 2 000 years ago and
dish it up for you and say here's a meal
eat it internalize it think like us
wander after us so the fateful decision
to bring in regular sunday keeping was
made
in the time when telesporus
headed the church in rome he died within
a year of hadrian's
addict his successor was igneous 136-49
so within the first hundred years
everything was a disaster
john the last deci the last one of the
barely died and this was already
already happened happening now we
continue our historic saga
the new day of worship was firmly
entrenched by the time of pius
the first which is 140 255 a.d
you know i don't like the modern
connotation
before the common era or after the
common era
we'll stick to the old and make christ
the center
in his apology justin martyr a
contemporary of pius the first provided
the first christian
rationale for sunday observance now what
did he write
he wrote sunday dear solace is the day
on which we all hold our common assembly
because it is the first day on which god
having wrought a change in the darkness
and matter
made the world and jesus christ our
savior on the same day
rose from the dead
anything biblical there no is this
argument being used to this day today
100 and it's only the second part
basically
and but it's also important to know that
justin martyr
was a christian he was supposed to be
a true christian correct now had god
said
rest on the first day because i made
light on the first day or did he rest on
the seventh day
he rested on the seventh day okay
so the apology was added addressed to
the emperor
antoninus pius about 1850
justin's word choice is significant
the mithraic diaz solace day of the sun
instead of
the new testament semitic first day of
the week
this was intended to ingratiate him and
other christians with this important
roman leader
so this flirting with the state
was taking place then already didn't you
say that flattery
in our previous one career is part of
coercion
yes and jesus said render unto caesar
what is due unto caesar and unto god
what is due unto god
my kingdom is not of this world so
this is the compromise that led
to the dark ages eventually and
do you think we will have the same type
of compromise now at the end of time
absolutely so
justin mata was really wasting his time
says this historian
because he was modded after all right
so justin martyr was really a roman
nationalist with syncretic tendencies
right
justin shared the anti-semitism of his
compatriots he
argued in his dialogue with trifo
that the observance of the sabbath was a
temporary
mosaic ordinance which god
imposed exclusively on the jews
as a mark to single them out for
punishment
that they so well deserve for their
infidelities
now the author here says what an
ignorant man and that's true he's
being very ignorant here we hear the
same sentiment today
yes but you know what is interesting
martin
here he's saying that it was a
punishment for the jews and the sabbath
was for the jews
was there a jew in the first day of
creation no
no right abraham was not jewish as
either
no did you know that the word jew
doesn't actually occur in the bible
it's just been translated like that even
in the king james it's actually judean
yeah so this is a very interesting
statement
you know who else says that the sabbath
keeping
and many of the laws were
only because of the disobedience of the
jews
the quran the quran says exactly the
same thing
in other words ignore god's sabbath
ignore god's health laws because the
quran
also says that all those health laws
excepting for the pig
[Music]
only applied to the jews because of
their disobedience
actually and the sabbath too yeah so
it's actually a punishment
so actually they are using an old old
argument
that comes from those church fathers
and then it said that
god said you must make the sabbath a
delight
yes and they make it it was a punishment
punishment
excellent point this was typical of an
entire theology
lasting for centuries a so-called
christian separation from and contempt
towards the jews
characteristic jewish customs such as
circumcision and sabbath-keeping were
proclaimed to be a sign
of jewish depravity these laws had been
instated by god
and they were actually pointing towards
christ exactly
so at the council of laodicea now it
gets
fascinating because now we're at a stage
where this power block has grown
to the point where it's starting to flex
its
muscles it does not yet
have secular power no it's only in the
religious
it has religious power but it has
influence
with the state so at the council of
laodicea
sometime between 343 and 381
catholicism sought to eliminate the
observance of the seventh day
completely so it took them 300
years yeah to try and get rid of it
right
that must tell you something correct
by the way he says this incidentally is
part of the proof
that even in those years some christians
persisted in observing the seventh day
so here you have a source a historic
source because why would they make such
a strong decree against it if nobody was
keeping it
right so that's why if everybody were
adhering to it in the second century
already they wouldn't have to have these
councils
200 years later exactly now
what is interesting so here they
decreed against the sabbath
martin do we have similar things
happening today
are they agitating for a day yes they're
agitating for a day
definitely would they be agitating for a
day if there was no opposition
exactly no they weren't no they wouldn't
right
so in ad 135 the pope deliberately
separated his church not only from the
jews but also from the olive tree of
israel
in other words he said we have nothing
to do with that jewish history
that's basically taking a pair of
scissors and cutting the old testament
off
and justifying it by using the old
testament
yes that's circular reasoning right
in this way the pontificate became the
antichrist
it and the system it headed forfeited
the covenant rights
of yavers israel announced to abraham
the fountainhead
of blessings for all the families of
earth
and fulfilled in the messiah who is also
the creator and lord of the sabbath mark
2 28. so here we have
the full catastrophe of how this
developed
and the mere fact that it came like my
cat crawling onto the dog
slowly piece by piece shows you
that there was a war and it's
interesting what you just mentioned
earlier
that currently we see the same thing
happening
with a day and is it coincidence that
it's that same
first day of the week always that they
slowly
and how did it go it progressed until it
became
law now we must look at this law very
carefully because i've been thinking
about this law
and we'll see what what it leads to
so let's go to the council of laodicea
as decisive as is this evidence
it is not the strongest that we have to
offer
historians early and late of all beliefs
have made much mention of the action of
the council of laodicea
ad364 mcclintock and strong
made the following statement christostom
now the americans will say christastone
in id 360 concludes one of his homilies
by dismissing his audience to their
respective ordinary occupations
the council of laodicea a.d
364 however enjoined christians to rest
on the lord's day
this puts it in a very mild indeed
in regard to the influence of the
decision of this council they say
60 canons were published which were
accepted by the other churches
in their synopsis of these they say
canon 29
forbids christians observing the jewish
sabbath so here for the
first time they are using this term
jewish
sabbath over and over in their official
documents
and it's interesting to me martin that
they forbid christians
not jews no to keep yes the sabbath
because you will see that this theology
eventually develops
where you have two groups and
let's see where that leads to in these
two statements we get the whole truth
one
it enjoined the observance of the first
day of the week
and two it forbade the observance of the
sabbath
let it be remembered that this council
was held in less than half a century
from the time when
constantine issued his first decree
for the observance of the venerable day
of the sun
as the day of rest from labour
he made a sunday rest law correct
but the council of ludditzia the
catholic church
expanded it to include a anti-sabbath
law
can we expect the same thing martin
we're seeing the race day
we've shown it over and over yes the
european alliance
for this race day everybody
now as we saw in the first video
it was stated that this so-called
antichrist that was to come
ignoring the one that is already there
was going to force everyone to keep the
seventh day as the sabbath
but they don't realize the christians
when they cling to that idea
is that according to that theology the
christians will be gone
yeah it doesn't affect the christians no
because they'll be re
raptured supposedly raptured let's use
that supposedly yes yes
with this secret rapture so if we
continue here with the council of
laodicea
we read as the historian says it was
taken from the hands of the emperors by
popes
and councils and rest enforced upon
it as a christian festival
i will here copy the original as given
by the council itself
in latin now the readers can read it for
themselves
and we will translate it in the
translation the following is a
translation
christians ought not to judaize
and to rest on the sabbath
but to work on that day so there is the
anti-sabbath law
you must work on that day but preferring
the lord's day
should rest if possible as christians
wherefore if they shall be found to
judah eyes
let them be accursed from christ that's
pretty
straightforward so this is the roman
catholic law and this was
roman catholic law that was enforced
correct
so this is an ex catheter law
so it is infallible you cannot change it
no
and maybe skeptics can just take note
of what happened here yes it's not only
not
being able to do anything on a sunday
for sunday rest
this was also enforcing people not to
keep
the truth sabbath correct
so martin what was the conclusion of
that decision at the council of laodicea
the christian religion had been accepted
by the emperors
they became the champions constantine
had introduced the first
sunday arrest law and now by the time of
justinian it was being enforced
so historically in less than a century
after leo's decision
justinian subjected all whether jew
gentile or christian to the catholic
faith
of which the substitution of the sunday
for the sabbath was a prominent
part of which they had to make a public
profession within three months
under penalty of being declared infamous
excluded from all employment rendered
incapable of leaving anything by will
and having their states of whatever
nature confiscated
martin are they talking about
legislation of that nature
they world economic forum exactly all
right they haven't linked it to a day
yet but they're working on it
and they're working on it because
climate change
exactly that's what i'm saying they're
working on it
so if we jump forward
to the council of trent where the
jesuits were totally
in control this council took place
after the reformation and as we saw in
previous lectures
many many things were restored
by the reformation but even the
reformers
yes themselves argued about the sabbath
issue
and here at the council of trent where
they
said the reformers said sola scriptura
the bible and the bible alone
the sunday sabbath issue was the key
as to why rome could condemn
protestantism because the archbishop of
reggio
walked into this council and said you
protestants
you say sola scripture but you keep
sunday which is
a law of the roman catholic church now
you can see it in history i've shown it
therefore you are not protestants
you are rebels
and rome passed its decrees
and negated every tenet of the
reformation
if we go a little bit further to vatican
which we will deal with in the next few
sessions that we will have we will see
that they never changed one
single decree from the council of trent
yes they can't it has to be in harmony
with the council of laodicea
so here you had a mini repeat of that
battle
and protestantism failed yes
so basically at the first vatican
council at the council of trent
every single rule and law based on
tradition
that the roman catholic church had
introduced even
since that early time was
firmly established
they condemned protestantism
on the issue of sabbath sunday
keeping and then they had to move
further because the reformation
also not only introduced
christ again as the center of the
religion
and the scripture as the standard but
they had condemned the papacy as
antichrist
so having condemned the reformation they
now had to find a counter
for this antichrist label
yes enter the jesuits
with two doctrines pre-terrorism
and futurism and it is important for
viewers in other christian denominations
to realize
sunday keeping has been coming
forth from the roman church absolutely
even from pagan times
from pagan times and there were laws
that were implemented especially from
the 4th century
that persecuted anybody keeping their
true sabbath
correct and so it went on for centuries
and now we get to
like you said a thousand years later
correct so by now the remembrance
of the true sabbath has been replaced
with tradition yes and didn't jesus
in the commandments say remember the
servant
so maybe it was going to be forgotten
right
well let's have a look at these two
issues pre-terrorism and futurism
it's fascinating to me that the jesuit
world can put two
opposing doctrines into the world
out of the same organization
and that the christian world would buy
into both
it's ridiculous because they're
diametrically opposed to one another
and it's interesting that even within
one denomination
often both are propagated which is
impossible right yeah
so where does preterism come from and
what does it say alcaza
alcazar was the jesuit who who
propounded it
by the pre-terrorist interpretation all
the prophecies relating to the
antichrist were pushed
back in an endeavor to find their
fulfillment before the collapse of the
roman
empire that would set the pope free
and exonerate him from this title
so praetorism claims that the antichrist
was an individual even though the bible
says many antichrists
was an individual and that
that was antiochus epiphanes the fourth
a greek
king the trouble with this theory of
course
is that this little horn power of daniel
comes out of the fourth kingdom which is
rome so he cannot be a greek king
so that even anybody should believe this
is amazing i once had a minister from a
protestant denomination
come to my house with a young man
to try and convince me
that the papacy was not antichrist he
was a pre-terrorist
and the young man was sitting there and
this man the
the pastor was trying to convince me
that antiochus epifanus was
the antichrist so i took the bible and
we went through daniel chapter 7
and i showed him the kingdoms and it is
very clear in the bible
that after the greek empire comes the
roman empire
and that this power arose out of
the roman remnants of the collapsed
roman empire
and i showed it to them in the bible and
i said so it can't be a greek king it
has to be
after the roman era and eventually he
got so frustrated
he closed the ears of his young
companion
and watched him out of the house he
didn't want him to hear those things
so let's just go into this a little bit
so
maybe please everybody open your ears
yes and let's listen to this listen
alcaza
a spanish jesuit taking a hint from
victorinos
seems to have been the first and this is
81 614
to have suggested that the apocalyptic
prophecies did not extend further than
the overthrow
of paganism by constantine it has been
usual to say
that the spanish jesuit alcaza in his
writings was the founder of the
praetorist school
this is history here are the writings of
alcazar there you see
the jesuit emblem over there
and this was his his view now it's
interesting that many of the protestant
churches
swallowed this hook line and sinker
especially the conservative churches
so many of the of the calvinist line
accepted pre-terrorism and taught it in
the seminaries
the same with the lutheran line they
also started
accepting pre-terrorism as an
alternative
explanation well once you get rid of the
purpose antichrist
then you're open to echomenism right
correct
now futurism is the opposite instead of
seeking a fulfillment in the past so
that it doesn't apply to the papacy
you seek to a fulfillment in the future
but the christian church must be gone
because the pope is associated with
christianity
yes correct so there was another jesuit
by the name of
ribera so he took those same prophecies
and held them off into the future
by dislocating the last week in daniel
and with no justification
throwing it into the future
declaring that the antichrist would make
his appearance after the coming of
christ
and ribera published a commentary in
containing these ideas now martin
if christ is going to come to set up his
kingdom then how can antichrist
set up his kingdom after christ it
doesn't make any sense
so they have to find a reason why christ
abandons the idea and leaves them for a
thousand years to do their thing down
here right yes
and this is where the rapture comes in
the secret rapture
so now this idea had to be expanded so
that
the church would be raptured away
and then only the jews would remain and
antichrist would reign
down here so let's look at this so
protestants today are divided between
modernist
and fundamentalists modernists
give very little place to the study of
prophecy and fundamentalists
are mainly futurists but some of the old
school protestants are still
preterists very confusing both jesuit
doctrines
you send twin lies into the world
diametrically opposed to each other
and it doesn't matter to them which one
you swallow
because either way the pope is not the
antichrist yes
so here is a francisco ribera he was a
jesuit doctor
of theology and he was born in spain and
you see that he
wrote this even before alcazar
so they came virtually simultaneously a
little bit apart
all right and he published it in 1590
here's a quote from the book romanism
and the reformation
this is the church of england view in
the 1800s still
to resist the use to which scripture
prophecy
was put by the reformers is no light or
unimportant matter the system of
prophetic interpretation
known as futurism does resist
this use it condemns the interpretation
of the reformers
this is church of england speaking in
the 1800s
it condemns the view of all these men
and of
all the martyrs and of all the
confessors and faithful witnesses
of of christ for long centuries
it condemns the albiganses the valdanzas
the wicklifites the hussites the
lollards
the lutherans the calvinists it condemns
them all
and upon a point upon which they are all
agreed
an interpretation of scripture with
their embodied in their solemn
confession and sealed with
their blood futurism gets rid of
protestantism
and protestants call themselves
protestants and their futurists then
what are they protesting against
they were nothing to protest against
they're no longer protestants yeah
and they're actually negating that the
antichrist system that protestants
stood up for yes they don't believe it
anymore
and then there was one very eloquent
bishop
also a jesuit of course the jesuits are
the avowed
enemy of protestantism and the only
reason why we have these doctrines in
the world
is is because of their skill
in selling a lie correct
cardinal robert bellamine is of course
now a saint
because he achieved so much yeah he was
the guy he was also mentioned by dr
taylor in the first video correct
he was one of the best known jesuit
apologists and he published between 1581
and 1593. can you see this all coming
out at the same time
and here is the latin title of what he's
saying
and basically it's lectures concerning
the disputed points of the christian
belief against the heretics of this
time the heretics being the protestants
of course
in which he also denied the day year
principle
in prophecy and pushed the reign of the
antichrist into a future period of three
and a half literal years
so the day your principle is gone as we
said
and the christian world swallows this
hook line and sinker
and thinks that they are protestants
now out of all of this then developed
dispensationalism because now you must
find a rationale
because remember christ is going to come
his church is going to be
raptured and the jews are going to reign
so how's this going to work so now you
have to do some fancy footwork
and come up with this doctrine so a
byproduct of futurism
is dispensationalism by which an
endeavor is made to divide history into
seven dispensations
as taught amongst others by scofield
so if you have a scofield bible then it
is replete in the comments with this
kind of theology
the advocates of this system say that
the dispensation of the kingdom
follows the dispensation of grace
at which time the jews will preach the
gospel of the kingdom to all the world
after the church has been raptured
and during this time the antichrist is
supposed to come
after entering into covenant
relationship with the jews
he will turn and persecute them but will
later be destroyed by the visible of
appearing of christ at the end of the
seven years
so now they've they've modified it
and they've created dispensation yes
because now they can justify
why there's a rap a secret rapture and
there's still
a kingdom on earth so you have the
christian period
which is the grace period and then you
will have the kingdom period
where the jews reign and christ returns
and he reigns from jerusalem but the
church is raptured and he's gone
yeah they stay in heaven so this gap
becomes very confusing
all right so let's look at the theology
carefully
here are the proponents of this idea
louis berry chaffer he's founder of the
dallas
theological seminary defines
dispensationalism in this word
the dispensationalist believes that
throughout the age god is pursuing
two distinct purposes one related to the
earth with
earthly people and earthly objectives
involved
which is judaism while the other is
related to heaven with heavenly
objectives involved which is
christianity
well fuller defines it a little bit
different he was the
dean of the fuller theological seminary
and he says the basic premise of
dispensationalism
is two purposes of god expressed in the
formation of two peoples who maintain
their distinction
throughout eternity
so god has two methods whereby he works
one that seems to have failed which he
postpones
and will make succeed at a later stage
and the other one is christianity
so dietrich bonhoeffer as you will
remember
will tell us that everybody was an
individual we've had this quote many
times so we don't have to repeat it so
you have an individual choice
but here you don't you have a group
choice yes you either belong to that one
or you belong to that one
how will it now work if you're a
christian jew
then you are exceedingly confused
uh but the messiah that you have as a
christian jew
is not the same messiah as in
christianity
because in in judaic
thinking the messiah is a national
deliverer
and not a deliverer from sin
now ray dunning writing in the beacon
dictionary of theology states
dispensationalism's most popular ideas
relate to its eschatological teachings
what happens at the end of time
the kingdom of heaven they say refers to
the earthly
nationalistic rule see where we go
which jesus offered to the jews but
which they rejected
thus god's program for israel had to be
postponed until later
and as an interim arrangement the church
age was
ushered in a further implication of this
is the dispensationalist teaching of a
secret
rapture of the church to remove the
church from earth
so god can re resume his original plan
of establishing a jewish earthly kingdom
very confusing but jesus was talking
about the kingdom of god he wasn't
talking ever
about a jewish earthly kingdom no and
that's why
jesus they expected the same when jesus
came the first time correct
nothing wrong with getting it wrong
twice is there
now pastor kevin gore is another one and
he says since you asked
why i disagree with the following five
pillars of dispensationalism so even
amongst themselves there's no agreement
and pastor gore does not agree with
dispensationalism and he has some very
good points
he writes dispensationalism's most
popular ideas
relate to the eschalogical teachings
building upon a
calvinistic view of covenant
as unconditional it is deeply interested
in national israel and her relation to
the land of palestine
which dispensationalists insist will be
possessed
in the end of time for the establishment
of an earthly
jewish kingdom in fulfillment of god's
promise
to david that's during the millennium
we've got some eruptions going on in
israel correct in the news we must never
forget
that the jewish state as we have it
today
is an artificial entity
created post-war by
finance and money coming from
the secret societies of the world let's
just put it simply
like that so if we if we can state it
like this
to uphold this
futurism and dispensationalism
they literally put the jewish nation
there correct to keep this alive correct
but it still in its tenet rejects
jesus christ as the messiah who had come
they're waiting for the one
to come but the one who is to come is a
national deliverer
and not a deliverer of the person the
individual
from this evil called sin
so there are five pillars to
dispensationalism
firstly there's this claim to a
consistent
literal interpretation of scripture
now you have a problem there because
when israel will reign then all these
ancient
nations will serve them if you take the
bible literally
but they don't exist anymore so what do
you do now
do you resurrect them as well in order
to have a literal
fulfillment secondly the belief that god
has a two-fold plant and purpose for
mankind one that
specifically concerns the ethnic nation
of israel and one that specifically
concerns the christian
church the one has to
believe in christ and the other one
doesn't
the belief that the church is not one
with spiritual israel so
when the bible talks about the people of
god
being the israel of god that's spiritual
israel they reject that they only accept
a literal israel
not a spiritual israel
the belief in a secret rapture of the
church from this earth
prior to god resuming his original plan
of establishing a jewish earthly kingdom
so god wasn't successful he he postponed
the idea
and put something in its place and then
fifth the belief in a future millennial
kingdom of christ on earth before the
ushering in of a new heaven and a new
earth
so they have to build a temple and
they must have somebody come in there
for seven years to rule
and for three and a half years he will
suppress
god's people that's the theology
well if they could get a whole nation
there
they might as well be able to build a
new temple
absolutely as a diversion let's see what
they do but then all
attention is on jerusalem and not on
what's happening in rome
exactly this is all being done to take
the label of antichrist away
from the papers yes and the
enemy sits over there
in terms of the many nations that are
around that are not of the jewish faith
neither of the christian
faith their attention is not directed
towards rome
but towards this other entity it's a
very clever diversion
keeping half of humanity
on the one side and the other half in
the illusion that the pope is not the
antichrist
so let's see how he sums it up
dispensationalism insists that the
earthly promises
which were made to abram were made
exclusively with him
and with his physical seed scripture
however states to the contrary
romans 2 28 and 29 he is not a jew who
is one outwardly
this totally negates their theology
romans 9 6 they are not all
israel which are of israel that negates
that theology
galatians 3 29 they that are christ's
are abraham's seed
that makes the church spiritual
israel exactly galatians 3 14
that the blessings of abraham may come
on the gentiles
in christ jesus that's spiritual israel
and galatians 3 28 for ye are all
one in christ jesus there is no
dispensation
salvation has been the same from the
beginning
god does not change nothing has changed
thus he concludes that the new covenant
does not pertain to the physical nation
of israel
but it pertains to the whole family of
god the true
israel of faith
and this is a biblical view this is a
biblical view
so let's just recap again the council of
trent
established the roman catholic doctrine
infallibly cannot be moved
the second vatican council did it change
the roman catholic position
established at the council of trent
answer is
no we will prove that in subsequent
lectures
nothing has been changed only an
apparent change
very clever very clever like we've seen
they've worked like this throughout
history millennia they've
they're not stupid no they're not stupid
they know how to do this
so let's look at the remnant of israel
after their national rejection of the
messiah
the jews could still be saved as
individuals
though henceforth heaven's appointed
agency for blessing and evangelizing the
planet would be the christian church as
paul announced and as peter announced
and they are the verses
the apostle meant that the christian
church originated and therefore
continues
as a remnant of israel
and even the book of revelation still
talks about jews
yes it doesn't talk about christians
that name only originated at antioch
so when the when revelation talks about
those that say that there are jews or
not
this is what it's talking about means
the people of god was talking to the
christian remnant
so romans 11 1-5 i say then has god cast
away his people
god forbid for i also am an israelite of
the seed of abraham of the tribe of
benjamin
god has not cast away his people which
he foreknew
what ye not what the scripture says of
elias
i maketh intercession to god against
israel saying lord they have killed thy
prophets and dig down thine altars
and i am left alone and they seek my
life
but what says the answer of god unto him
i have reserved to myself seven thousand
men who have not bowed the knee to the
image of baal
even so then at this present time also
there is a remnant
according to the election of grace it's
very clear
correct so continues those who accepted
jesus christ
out of the jews and any jew who accepts
jesus christ as his personal savior
through all the time periods until the
close of probation
will be part of the israel of god
whether they were literal jews or
whether they were not
so who were the remnant originally it
consisted
entirely of believing jews those early
christians
jesus the messiah is not was
a jew in his
only theological argument with a gentile
the woman at the well of samaria he even
said salvation is of the jews
they had the plan of salvation in type
christians have it in verity that's a
type had met antitype
it hasn't replaced it's a continuation
no
in fact dispensationalists call what we
are talking about now
replacement theology and they condemn it
but there cannot be a different gospel
because revelation says you have to
preach what kind of gospel
the everlasting everlasting gospel it
never changes
every single one of the apostles was a
jew the new testament is a
jewish book written by hebrews with the
possible exception
of luke christianity began in palestine
with the remnant of israel and not
as a gentile institution
the mother of christianity was not rome
but jerusalem not the catholic church
but the church of the
east hopefully this will
make it clear i'm i hope so yes
history clarifies where we are in the
stream of time correct
so modern history is very important
in seeing the progression of
the apostasy coming into the church
right yes
and we can see that there was conflict
and the church in the east and the
church in the west
were in conflict with each other as well
now it's interesting that eventually
rome basically succeeded
in taking over everything yeah and
its liturgies and the way in which they
did things
started creeping in but the bibles were
still different
the church in the east used the received
text and the one in the west
started moving over to
the the latin bible and
the vulgate etc and the translations
that came out of it
and then eventually a split game between
uh the orthodox church and the catholic
church although their liturgies were
very
similar and they'd already adopted many
of the
things of catholicism this split
evolved because of
an argument about who had supremacy
whether it was the bishop of rome or
whether it was
the one in constantinople and so they
split
and some issues have still not been
resolved to this day
so this is one of the splits that they
want to solve
and we need to just briefly before we
wrap up
just look at a few issues that pertain
to this history that make it interesting
so
let's look at unity between the catholic
church and the orthodox church
so in the recent past this concept of
french president de gaulle speaking of a
european from kalei to the urals
as the real europe has also been
cherished by pope john
paul ii the jewel in the pope's
international design
is a utopian vision of a unified and
re-christianized europe stretching from
the atlantic to the euro mountains
where of course the papacy will be
supreme right
correct phase one would be
an end to the division between eastern
and western europe
phase two reconciliation between the
roman catholics and the orthodox
christians of the soviet east
because originally the the east was
under the
bishop of constantinople which is today
istanbul but eventually
it shifted to the greek orthodox church
where
this power was residing and then
eventually when
arguments occurred there was a move even
to the russian patriarch
they're all a little bit on a different
page but more or less coming together
yeah in these efforts today this unity
has already
been sorted out in the political sphere
correct
and also behind the scenes it has been
sorted out
in the religious sphere but it takes
time
to make it further through to the
through the whole system
so here is a catholic news agency pope
francis
tells orthodox leader i'm confident we
will achieve
full unity so they're working at it
right at
super speed now but francis tells the
economical patriarch of constantinople
monday that he is confident
that catholics and orthodox christians
will
attain full communion we can thank god
that relations between the catholic
church and the economical patriarchate
had grown much over the past century
even as we continue to yearn for the
goal of the restoration of full
communion
expressed through participation at the
same
eucharistic altar they always bring in
the
sacrifice that made them priests right
the pope sends a message each year on
november 30 to the economical patriarch
who is regarded as the successor of
saint andrew the apostle and the first
amongst equals in the eastern orthodox
church
cardinal quadcock president of the
pontifical council for the promotion of
christian unity
led the delegation and after the divine
liturgy coch read the pope's message and
presented the economical
patriarch with a signed copy so there's
this attempt to unify them
so just a few months later martin they
come up with this message
vatican cardinal supports common easter
date for catholic and orthodox
now this takes us back in history again
because a lot of people won't understand
now so we have to
enlighten them what just line it up with
history again
so this easter which was
the annual festival became a
weekly festival that's how sunday came
into the church
right but the eastern church
celebrated easter on a different time
so if you want total unity then
everything has to be in harmony with the
one who changed
exactly and who is that that's wrong
correct
so now it's fascinating that they're
working towards a common easter day
a representative of the patriarchate of
constantinople
to the world council of churches said a
common easter date
could be a sign of encouragement to the
economical movement
how long has this taken martin almost
two thousand
years yes isn't this fascinating yes
and it's all moving towards one point
orthodox archbishop getcha
suggested that the year 2025
which will be the 1700th
anniversary of the first ecumenical
council of nisei it would be a good year
to introduce this reform of the calendar
i always like that date because that's
what alisay bailey said when the
externalization of the hierarchy would
take place in other words when demons
will manifest themselves
interesting that they're also again
looking at
meddling with a calendar correct
he's the one who changes times and laws
the first council of nisaya was held in
decided that easter would be celebrated
on the first
sunday after the full moon
following the beginning of spring making
the earliest possible date for easter
march 22
and the latest possible one april 25
today orthodox christians use the julian
calendar
to calculate the easter date instead of
the gregorian calendar
which was introduced in 1582. now it's
interesting that the
jesuits were behind the introduction of
the gregorian calendar
and is used by most of the world because
the julian calendar
calculates a slightly longer year it is
currently 13 days behind the gregorian
calendar
and just before we get another question
on this nothing of the julian or the
um gregorian calendar changed the cycle
of the week
so the sabbath is still on the saturday
correct so
didn't change it was the seventh day of
the week it did not take
roman it shifted the date but it didn't
change the cycle of the week
now let's just go to another interesting
statement just to
put another little bit of information in
there
now if you go to wikipedia
you will find this definition now
this definition is in many sources
historic sources
but just to show the readers that we can
use
a a modern open source even
and even that can have information in
that
applies to this argument and you will
see
how important it is here is a term which
is called quarto
decimanism what does that mean
the quarto deciman controversy arose
between
christians in the churches of jerusalem
in asia minor
observed the passover on the 14th
of the month nissan now nissan is the
first
month in the jewish calendar and it
starts with spring
no matter the day of the week on which
it occurred
because they determined it by the lunar
cycle
yes so this was a month
issue when did the month start had
nothing to do with the cycle of the week
it had to do with a month
yes while the churches in and around
rome changed to the practice of
celebrating
easter always on the sunday
following the first full moon following
the vernal equinox calling it the day of
the resurrection of our savior
the difference was turned into an
ecclesiastical controversy when the
practice was condemned by the synods
bishops
so now let's just get to straight martin
the jews
under the pharisees and remember paul
says in his theology
as far as these things are concerned he
stands by the pharisees right
it was against the sadducees now
the pharisees calculated the 14th that's
why they were called
cuarto desaminists those who kept the
14th day
that day was determined by
the appearance of of the new moon
and it could take place any day of the
week
so every year it could shift to
another day but rome decided
no it had to be a sunday
the first day of the week it's
interesting
that the jewish sadducees
also were inclined to have it as the
first day of the week so they were at
loggerheads with the pharisees
so now an argument arose this just goes
to show
how important this annual sunday was to
them
yes because the annual sunday of easter
was the door that opened up the
possibility
of the weekly sunday of the disputes
about the date when the lord's supper
should be
celebrated disputes known as
partial easter controversies the quatto
deciman is the first recorded so they
argued about this
in the mid-2nd century the practice in
asia minor
was for the pre-partial fast to end
and the feast to be held on the 14th day
of nissan
this is the church of the east this is
where the true church was
the christians the christians yeah they
were first called christians at antioch
not in rome
when the bali was found ripe after the
new moon
near the jewish lunar month of nisan no
matter the day of the week on which it
occurred
the date on which the passover sacrifice
had been offered
when the second temple stood and the day
when the people put away the leaven
those who observed this practice were
called
cuarto desimani latin for fourteenth
because of holding their celebration on
the 14th day
of nisan so when they changed this
calendar
to bring it in line by the way with the
pagan calendar and the feast of isis
or the feast of ishtar which became
easter
again the one changing the times and the
laws is
rome and nobody else no future
antichrist who will come
this issue was important so now they
celebrate easter and the crucifixion
always on a friday and the resurrection
always on a
sunday it was not the case in the early
church
and like we've seen that's why when the
weekly
sunday keeping came in they called it a
mini easter
correct so now let's just go back to
history an early example
was the demand by pope victor
this is now 189-99 of the christ
that all should celebrate easter on
sunday see the history
confirmed now there in a modern
open encyclopedia
he went further he excommunicated the
christians in the roman
province of asia who continued to
observe it on nissan 14
because they would get rid of the annual
sunday
easter right the date of the jewish
passover the papal invention
of easter sunday was tinged with
paganism
nevertheless at the council of nisaya
the emperor constantine supported it and
imposed it on
all its territories so he got
rid of the original biblical
times and introduced his own times not a
future antichrist the pope did it yes
it can happen because the
the biblical one changes over time right
then it can
be on any time of the week but
occasionally
it can actually coincide with the same
time that
rome has but rome wants to
distance itself from the biblical way
and enforce its way that it is on a
sunday and a sunday determined by
it not the bible correct this is
actually an arrogance
no this is 100 directly opposing god
exactly so now in 2001
what happened was they coincided and the
pope
who was on the throne at the time was
pope john paul ii
so what did he do as in previous
occasions he shifted the solemnity of
easter by a week and the entire western
world followed him
not thinking how can you move
this by a week
isn't that changing times yes it's
changing even within his own system he
changed his own times
so in 2001 the writer says he was
completing
this book full moon fell on the sunday
the 8th of april which coincided with
the jewish passover
easter was therefore delayed a week and
celebrated on sunday the 15th
of april so catholicism in its
theological kindred boasted against the
olive tree of israel
quite deliberately they detached
themselves from it
and god has honored their decision do
what you want
i will give you permission to change
that or i will allow it
but people must decide how much blood
has flowed over history
over this issue let's go back to
wikipedia
the practice had been followed by
polycarp
who was a disciple of john the apostle
so polycarp
had received his instruction directly
from john the apostle
and he kept the 14th day
and the bishop of smyrna one of the
seven churches of asia
and by melitta of sardis now irenaeus
we've heard him before
says that polycarp visited rome when
anicetus was the bishop
and among the topics discussed was the
divergent
of custom with rome celebrating the
easter
always on sunday so now we're going back
right into history right to the source
here was an argument
the one group was keeping it the bible
way the other one was keeping it the
roman way
according to eusebius now eusebius was a
gnostic
yes he was a follower of oregon he was a
contemporary of constantine
and he's probably the one who
wrote much of the bible in such
a way that it could be of economical
value
bringing pagans and christians together
and maybe the manuscripts that were
found that syneticus
the syneticus is one of these
modified versions by this
eusebius fellow so in the last decade
a number of synods were convened to deal
with the controversy
ruling unanimously that the celebration
of easter should be observed and be
exclusively on sunday
so rome put down its stamp synods and
conferences of bishops were convened
and drew up a decree of the church in
the form of letters addressed to
christians everywhere that never on any
day
other than the lord's day should the
mystery of the lord's resurrection from
the dead be celebrated
and on that day alone we should observe
the end
of the east the fast
this controversy has been raging a long
time
they're going to nail it now they're
going to bring it to a point
so these synods were held in various
places
the council in rome presiding by its
bishop
victor took place in 193 and sent a
letter about the
matter to polykratis of ephesus
and the churches of the roman province
of asia
so within the same year polycrytis
presided over the council of
ephesus attended by several bishops
throughout that province
and they rejected victor's authority and
kept the province's partial traditions
so the church in the east said no we're
not going to do what rome says we're
going to stick to the bible
so what did he do he excommunicated
him that seems to be a way to do it
right yeah
you're not going to become you're not
going to be able to buy you're not going
to do yourself
i'm going to throw you out exactly
palikratus emphatically stated that he
was following the tradition passed down
to him
we observe the exact day neither adding
nor taking away for in asia also great
lights have fallen asleep
which shall rise again on the day of the
lord's coming
that's interesting so what if they
believe on the resurrection
that they at jesus is coming the date
will be raised again
exactly so all these observed the 14th
day of the passover according to the
gospel
deviating in no respect but following
the rule of faith and i
also polycrytus the least of you all
do according to the tradition of my
relatives some of whom i have closely
followed for seven of my relatives were
bishops
and i am the eighth and my relatives
always
observed the day when the people put
away the leaven
quite clear this controversy has been
raging
for 2 000 years
so now the question is will history
repeat itself
let's quote again from the source that
we've been quoting all along
by edwin the non-conformity has
ever been the badge of the persecuted
while their oppressors often belong to a
religion or ideology supported by the
state
the hardship that the christians
experienced often did not originate with
the
emperor but with their neighbors who
stirred up trouble
you know i can't resist stopping there
for a while
are we experiencing similar things
yes where is the problem
of being handed over to the authorities
yes
your neighbour's going to hand you over
tell us about these things they're
saying
to these the followers of christ were
atheists
since they would not worship the roman
gods or venerate images
according to robin fox in his book
pagans and christians
the pagans believed that this was very
bad
for their gods were supposed to be
extremely jealous of their rights
if anybody dishonored them they could
turn
very nasty and punish the whole
community with famine plague a drought
no rain because of the christians became
a common saying
martin do you think they could say that
the climate change catastrophes
can be blamed on those who refuse to
conform
to roman laws you think it's a
possibility
in 161 marcus aurelius assumed the
purple
the emperor's view of life were also
singularly enlightened for instance he
referred to
the idea of a polity in which
there is the same law for all
a polity administered with regard to
equal rights and equal freedom of speech
and the idea of a kingly government
which respects
most of all freedom of the governed
now it's interesting martin is that
today they say the same thing
provided this in harmony with the common
good yeah
here he seems to be anticipating some of
the principles which more than 1
600 years later came to adorn the
american bill of rights
and are justly admired all over the
world we would have expected this
emperor to be more tolerant than the
rest of the romans but he was not
for it appears that christian blood flow
more profusely in the
principle of marcus aurelius the
philosopher than it had before
i think it can happen again martin yes
i think it's important to realize
although
that leader might seem
so kind and so liberal don't
underestimate them
correct that he of all the ancient
romans could also be the relentless
persecutor has perplexed his admirers
and after times
we must simply accept that however much
the ideas and even the life of marcus
aurelius resembled those of the
christians
he regarded them as enemies threatening
the stability of rome
we can only ponder the tragic fact that
persecutors
doomed to perdition are often highly
respectable
and apparently virtuous people
the deception runs so deep
and today we have a system
where the moral leaders of the world
are embracing all those pagan ideologies
in placing it into the books of the
legislature
and telling the world to conform
for the common good may god give us
wisdom
because if we understand this this issue
then like those early christians of the
east we will say
thus says the lord the issue will be
the weekly sabbath the others have been
sorted by them but the cycle of the week
has not changed
so the weekly sabbath is going to be the
issue may god give us
wisdom heavenly father
we have taken a walk
through the corridors of history
this issue has been coming a long long
time
that antichrist power that assumed the
power to change
times and laws is
now gathering his people from the east
and from the west
and may there be a people worldwide that
will oppose him
and says thus says the lord is my prayer
in jesus name
amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe to our channel
click here to get notifications click on
the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again